wir schalten jetzt zu paul und sag uns
einmal wie du in diesen stunden vitali
klitschko erlebt was ist sein
tagesprogramm und wie schaut er
möglicherweise heute auch aus kiew auf
das was sich da in moskau abspielt
ja keine modelle klitschko seit die
beiden seit 20 bleibt den und jammerte
morgen um acht uhr zusammen gefrühstückt
sonntag beginnt der frühe hinter mir
stehst du wie erste statements gibt
gerade in diesem moment und es ist etwas
als eine besondere situation es hier hat
eine gedenkveranstaltung gerade
stattgefunden für ukrainische soldaten
die in den 70er jahren denn die
sowjetunion geschickt und und vitali
klitschko hat daran erinnert wie schlimm
krieg ist und dass krieg verhindert
werden muss heute morgen haben wir
darüber gesprochen dass oder schuld
jetzt machen muss wieder die besagte mir
jetzt ein gutes zeichen gestern dass er
daran gedacht hat das bild von abscheu
für eine kerze
entzündet hat und an die menschen
gedacht hatte ich dort gestorben sind
und jetzt bereitet gerade erneut in
kassel statements vor hinter mir danach
geht es ins bürgermeisterhaus er trifft
mehrere bürgermeister aus verschiedenen
ländern und natürlich geht es die ganze
zeit darum was passiert in ihr die
dramatisch ist die lage immer wieder
kommen neue sicherheitsdetails dahin auf
die frage was macht das militär und wie
gut ist die hauptstadt vorbereitet denn
das erste mal ist es so dass auch hier
gefährdet ist und dass man sagt hier
könnte angegriffen werde jetzt hinter
mir viele menschen immer wieder hier zu
vitali klitschko dran ist und bleibt der
star ist der bekannteste mann mit seinem
bruder der ukraine wie bereitet man sich
dort paul auf einen etwaigen krieg vor
was sagt auch vitali klitschkos zu
seinen landsleuten wie sie sich darauf
vorbereiten sollen vitali klitschko
versucht zum einen zu beruhigen und zu
sagen wir sind auf alles vorbereitet man
hat hier zum beispiel bunker und keller
in den vergangenen tagen vorbereitet man
bereitet eine sogenannte zivile
verteidigung vor auch vitali klitschko
sagt er wäre bereit zu kämpfen an der
front genauso wie sein bruder wladimir
klitschko aber natürlich geht es hier
vor allem auch um das organisatorische
was passiert wenn es ein stromausfall
gibt man plötzlich die alles lahmgelegt
was passiert wenn russische soldaten
möglicherweise an einer grenze das wäre
dann die grenze in belarus wo diese
russischen soldaten stationiert sind
schnell die richtung hier geht aber die
hoffnung ist weiter da das ist eine
friedliche lösung geben könnte dass es
eine möglichkeit gibt dass olaf scholz
heute druck macht unser kanzler in
moskau damit in der ukraine weiter
frieden herrscht das ist die hoffnung
aber ich spüre auch nervosität hier ganz
klar eine nervosität ich so in dieser
hauptstadt und ich fahre den jahren
hierher noch nie gespürt habe scholz der
heute in die augen von vladimir putin
schauen muss sind diese finsteren augen
hier hinter uns und paul der den ganzen
tag sich an der seite von witali
klitschko bewegt noch ganz kurz paul was
steht da an wie ich sieht seinen
tagesplan heute aus hat was sind die
nächsten stationen
also wir fangen jetzt von hier mitten in
der stadt in richtung bürgermeisterhaus
das liegt in der nähe des bei da das ist
der dax wieder clinton klitschkos damals
gekämpft hat auch für die demokratie für
die freiheit danach gibt es verschiedene
bürgermeister dieder treffen wird unter
anderem aus prag und warschau
dann gibt er interviews trifft militärs
zivilisten also ein voller tag näher
dran kann man nicht sein dass paul
ronzheimer in diesen stunden in der
ukraine danke für das gespräch mit dir
du machst du jetzt auf den weg mit
vitali begleitete ihn durch diesen tag
während sich das andere geschehen in
moskau abspielt